Democrats scream as Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell sets the
impeachment rules couch and piece house
impeachment managers and Trump's lawyers
open up their cases and Joe Biden tries
to defend himself over Hunter's
corruption I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn why haven't you gotten a VPN
yet check out express it VPN comm slash
bet well you may have noticed the world
seems kind of chaotic these days from
possible conflict in the Middle East to
the impeachment fiasco that is currently
taking place of an election this year
things are gonna get more volatile and
so you may be looking for stability in
the markets especially because you got
half of economists saying that a
downturn is likely in the sometime near
future and some saying no it's gonna be
fine forever well why not just take a
little bit of your money and put it in
something that is never worth zero I'm
talking of course about precious metals
Fox Business just published an article
on how the world's richest people are
stockpiling precious metals right now as
part of their strategy to diversify
according to Goldman Sachs gold could
surge past 1600 bucks an ounce
within the next year so everybody who is
smart diversify is you should diversify
too if you have not yet taken the first
step of requesting a free information
kit on gold go ahead and do it and if
you're thinking about maybe taking a
portion of your eligible IRA or 401k and
putting it into an IRA in precious
metals you should have that conversation
you'll get all the information ask all
your questions
I trust the folks over at Birch gold
I've been working with them for years
Birch gold will go to work and make
things super simple for you no
obligations you have nothing to lose to
take that first step and ask all of your
questions
text Ben - 47 47 47 during the month of
January when you open an IRA in precious
metals you will get a signed copy of my
book the right side of history for free
which is pretty solid deal again yes it
texts Ben - 47 47 47 and open an IRA in
precious metals to get a signed copy of
my book the right side of history
and again ask all your questions get all
the information you need and then talk
about diversify go check out Birch gold
right now by texting Ben - 47 47 47 so
the impeachment trial is underway
excitement and oh cool all of it if you
feel like this whole thing is too
theatrical that's because it is it's
incredibly dumb it's incredibly
theatrical and none of it really is
gonna make a difference because we all
know where this is going the New York
Times basically admitting as much
yesterday Jesse Wegman a member of the
editorial board has an entire piece
lamenting the fact that the Democrats
don't actually have the goods he blames
that on Republicans because he's from
the New York Times is an article called
why Trump's threadbare legal argument
will probably work thanks a lot Mitch
McConnell or give you the sad that they
house wasn't unable or unwilling to
actually gather enough evidence to push
forward a credible impeachment effort
does that give you a sad is it sad that
Mitch McConnell is actually holding to
the same process as Bill Clinton's
impeachment is that really sad is it
really sad yesterday we saw an enormous
amount of on wrangling wrangling when it
came to the impeachment the the the
impeachment procedure according to the
new york times a divided Senate began
the impeachment trial of President Trump
on Tuesday and utter acrimony who could
have predicted utter acrimony in
Washington DC I mean these guys are like
the best of friends the most brilliant
among us Republicans blocked Democrats
efforts to subpoena witnesses and
documents related to Ukraine and
moderate Republicans forced last-minute
changes to rules that had been tailored
to the president's wishes so only one of
those things matters we're gonna hear
from the media today's Republicans were
blocking documents they're blocking
witnesses block block block block block
not true not true that was not this part
of the trial so what Mitch McConnell did
is he said here's the procedure we're
gonna have 12 hours well we're gonna
have 24 hours of arguments on each side
each side gets three days to make those
arguments and then after we make those
arguments then we can vote on which
documents to admit into evidence and
then we can also vote on witnesses and
Democrats instead like no to
preemptively vote on documents and
witnesses we're gonna do that before we
even hear the arguments because guess
what we got to get this thing going got
to move it fast it's imperative that we
move this thing fast and also we need to
call more witnesses that we didn't
bother calling in the house it's really
really fast but now we needed to slow up
guys we need to slow it up I mean we
really need to take our time and Mitch
McConnell is obstructing he's super
obstructing this is the way that they
are putting it right now Mitch McConnell
is screwing with the procedures Mitch
McConnell is not screwing with the
procedures the Republicans the more
moderate Republicans to be Romney and
Collins and Murkowski basically went to
mr. McConnell and they said you know
your original plan to have the Senate
here 24 hours of arguments from each
side in two days each that's too much
you know we want to go home we want to
sleep here we're kind of tired I mean
let's let's face it we're all old we're
all crotchety
we want to go home so instead we're
gonna do that over three days Mitch week
I was like well alright in his very
animated fashion well okay and so they
literally hand wrote in that change in
the impeachment rules and then they
moved on with their
and this is apparently a bombshell huge
this is just evidence that the
Republican caucus is starting to crack
meanwhile the Democrats who are
preemptively bringing all of these
subpoenas for witnesses and documents
they didn't bother to bring in the house
where they control the process
McConnell's like no we're not voting on
that stuff and even Romney and and
Murkowski and cons were like no we're
not going to vote on that stuff
preemptively even during the Clinton
stuff we didn't vote on this stuff
preemptively and the Democrats went nuts
over this so Chuck Schumer says Mitch
McConnell wants to trial with no
evidence and no new evidence he just
wants this is so mean it's something it
this is the first prosecution in history
that I can remember where the prosecutor
shows up at the court and his first move
is guys I know we're getting to a trial
now I need to go gather more evidence
you know it happened in like a normal
trial that the the judge would be like
well shouldn't you have gathered the
evidence before you brought this thing
to trial but according to Chuck Schumer
it's very bad that Mitch McConnell is
not admitting more evidence even before
he hears the arguments so here's Chuck
Schumer playing the fool unlike the
Clinton rules the McConnell resolution
does not admit the record of the house
impeachment proceedings into evidence so
McConnell seems to want a trial with no
existing evidence and no new evidence no
evidence you can understand why it's
because he's afraid of evidence so is
President Trump so are the president's
men a trial with no evidence is not a
trial at all it's a cover-up it's a
cover-up a cover-up but by the way they
changed the rules and then they admitted
all the house stuff all right so they
didn't admit any of the documents but
they did admit the actual house
impeachment record and so that has been
admitted as well so far as I understand
according to the New York Times in a
series of party line votes punctuating
12 hours of debate Senate Republicans
turn back every attempt by Democrats to
subpoena documents from the White House
State Department and other agencies as
well as testimony from White House
officials that could shed light on the
core charges against mr. Trump that
abate between the House and Pietschmann
managers and the president's legal team
stretched into the early hours of
Wednesday morning in a Senate chamber
transformed for the occasion with Chief
Justice John Roberts presiding from the
marble rostrum and senators sworn to
silence looking on from desks piled with
briefing books what was this
the substances start of the third
presidential impeachment trial in
American history and and all of this was
a Sharad all of this was simply theater
is just Jon Lovitz going acting that's
all this was even Mitt Romney who has
been relatively warmed for Democratic
attempts to open this thing up a little
bit more but even Mitt Romney was like
really we're arguing over a procedure
like it like now
shouldn't we argue over the subpoenas in
the witnesses you know a little bit
later and we're gonna pretend like this
is a big deal
here's Mitt Romney those milquetoast man
who has never lived changes are pretty
modest and I don't think are significant
in any dramatic way so for instance
whether something is going to be taking
12 hours per day or eight hours per day
it's still gonna get covered in the news
and what's officially go going into
evidence doesn't make a big difference
because the Senators are of course free
to look at all the information they have
that comes from the house so I think
those two issues are just not big ones I
think the Democrats make a mistake when
they claim outrage time and time again
if everything is an outrage then nothing
is an outrage then that of course is
true when Romney says that they are
acting outraged over everything as Ted
Cruz has pointed out the rule in court
is that if you have the facts you bang
the facts in if you have the law you
bang the law and if you don't have
either you bang the table and this is
what the Democrats are doing this
there's a lot on a table banging no not
like Bill Clinton style no no like
actually like this banging the table
like like hitting the table and shouting
about it Adam shifted a lot of that
yesterday so Adam chef who's the biggest
partisan hack in Congress right he spent
two years going on CNN every day I
remember every time I would go to
workout at the gym CNN would be on the
TV to my utter consternation and there
would be Adam Schiff on the TV his eyes
popping out like judge doom at the end
of Roger Rabbit explaining that we were
about to be graced with the final
chapter of the trump presidency thanks
to rush hour revelations and none of
that ever materialized here's Adam
Schiff no pretending that he is in
nonpartisan house impeachment manager he
is just here to do his solemn duty but
the big problem is people are gonna
think that the Senate's not impartial
okay I'm sorry listening to Adam Schiff
whine that the Senate is going to be
viewed as non impartial is just
hilarious on every level
why well here's what we found out
yesterday from Politico House
intelligence chairman Adam Schiff
appears to have mischaracterized a text
message exchanged between two players in
the Ukraine saga according to documents
obtained by Politico a possible error
the GOP will likely criticize as another
example of the Democrats a rushed effort
to impeach president Trump so I think
that Chef is making errors about the
record no I don't I think the chief is
biasing the record because he's a
partisan hack who lies about lots of
things the issue arose when shift sent a
letter to House Judiciary Chairman Jerry
Nadler last week summarizing a trove of
evidence from left Parnas an incited
former associate of trumps personal
attorney Rudy Giuliani in one section of
the letter Schiff claims the partners
can continue to try to arrange a meeting
with President zalenski setting a
specific text message exchange or Parnas
tells Giuliani trying to get us at mr. Z
the remainder of the exchange which was
attached to shifts letter was redacted
but an unredacted version of the
exchange it shows that several days
later Parnassus sent Giuliani a word
document that appears to show notes from
an interview with mcComish lo Jeff's key
the founder of buries m'a followed by a
test message to Giuliani the state's mr.
Z answers my brother which means that
Parnas was not trying to arrange a
meeting between Lev Parnas and Rudy
Giuliani and zalenski the president of
Ukraine who's trying to arrange a
meeting between Rudy Giuliani and had a
breeze moe which is who Rudy Giuliani
was investigating that makes a rather
large difference and Jeff knew that
right he'd seen the unredacted version
and then he just lied about it in his
letter hoping that nobody would notice I
love this this is the political
editorializing the apparent
mischaracterization does not undercut
Democrats argument that Trump withheld
critical military aid to Ukraine no
nobody said it did but you literally
mischaracterized the evidence on a
dramatic scale and that's just a
mischaracterization it's not a lie it's
a mischaracterization guys here's the
Adam Schiff complaining many Americans
might think that the Senate's not
impartial unless they do exactly what
Adam chef wants right now a great many
perhaps even most Americans do not
believe there will be a fair trial they
don't believe that the Senate will be
impartial they believe that the result
is precooked
the president will be acquitted not
because he is innocent he is not
but because the centers will vote by
party and he has the votes you mean like
in the house where every single
Republican voted no and every single
Democrat voted yes you mean even like
that like what are the impeachment was
precooked because everyone voted along
party lines and you couldn't convince a
single Republican across those party
lines because your evidence wasn't there
you mean I mean like that but I
definitely am up for hearing lectures
from Adam Schiff about partisan hackery
absolutely and then shift went after
Trump's lawyers saying that Trump's
lawyers are attacking Democrats to avoid
their own fellers this is shifts opening
statement yesterday he didn't bother to
actually argue about the impeachment
procedures instead he just launched into
this really long attack on Trump and
everybody was celebrating this morning
on Twitter hashtag Adam Schiff rocks was
trending which maybe was Russian BOTS
who knows here's Adam Schiff suggesting
that Trump's lawyers are attacking
Democrats because they don't have the
evidence dude you literally half of
shift speech was devoted to why aren't
Republicans gather more evidence cuz you
guys ran the house this is the head of
the House Intelligence Committee hit
every ability in the world to call
witnesses wait for the adjudication by
courts as to whether executive privilege
was invoked he didn't do any of that so
he shows up and he's like guys if you
could do my work for me like I didn't
finish my homework if you could do that
for me that'd be great and if you don't
you're a partisan hack more Adam Schiff
when you hear them attack the house
managers what you're really hearing is
we don't want to talk about the
president's guilt we don't want to talk
about the McConnell resolution and how
patently unfair it is we don't want to
talk about how how the pardon afresh the
expression asked backwards it is to have
a trial and then ask for witnesses and
so we'll attack the house managers
because maybe we can distract you for a
moment
from what's before you just ridiculous
ridiculous in every way because Adam
Schiff is ridiculous in every way and it
just shows you that Nancy Pelosi and the
Democrats they know where this is going
and they don't care they understand that
they didn't have any opportunity to
convince Republicans on the basis of
this evidence so they may as well let
Adam Schiff do his lecturing routine
they also sent and so he'll often
another partisan hack who explained the
evidence overwhelmingly proves Trump's
kill and that's why we need more
witnesses and more documents which again
is a strange argument here is Zoe
Lofgren from California the amendment
prevents the president from hiding
evidence as he is previously
tried to do now the house subpoenaed
these documents as part of the
impeachment inquiry but the president
completely rejected this and every
document subpoena from the house as
powerful as our evidence is and make no
mistake it overwhelmingly approves who's
his guilt we did not receive a single
document from the executive branch
agency including the White House itself
okay so I'm just gonna point out if what
evidence is overwhelming then why are
you calling for more evidence and for a
slowdown in the trial none of this makes
any sense then I do love this senator
mazie Hirono who is the worst I mean
she's just the worst if you remember
during the Cavanaugh trial she was the
one who was out there suggesting that
every wild story about Cavanaugh had to
be true she yesterday was saying anybody
who suggests that this is just a
democratic conspiracy to get Trump and
that this is all just about people
hating on Trump that's a conspiracy
theory we are fair-minded and impartial
and if you believe that then again that
bridge I have in Brooklyn is still for
sale
here is Senator mazie Hirono what we got
from the president's people were really
what I found astounding was they're
still saying that where we were all to
get the president from day one some kind
of a weird conspiracy theory that I have
to say even even Cavanaugh brought up
this they really believe this stuff I
find it incredible so they're still
focusing on the process there's a
conspiracy theory guys if you think the
Democrats are partisans and then the
Republicans are partisans and that
everybody's partisan that's a conspiracy
theory now that's a conspiracy there
okay so meanwhile president Trump's team
responds and responds in fiery fashion
so Pat's a baloney
he says listen we know what this is
about the Democrats are trying to
pretend the 2016 it was not legitimately
decided and then they're also trying to
say the 2020 will be illegitimate unless
President Trump is thrown from office
we'll get to Pat's if Alone's response
in just one second first let us talk
about the importance of the Second
Amendment so we watched this week as
thousands upon thousands of Second
Amendment advocates arrived at the
Capitol in Virginia to peacefully
protest an attempt to crack down on gun
rights and the media promptly attempted
to portray them as terrorists because
this is the battle that we are in we
have one part of the country and wants
to believe
everyone who is the Second Amendment
advocate is actually a terrorist and
those people are trying to cram down
these gun laws that are going to attempt
to take away our guns I mean bado it
works at it loudest during the 2016 2020
primaries he said absolutely I'm coming
for your AR hey the reason that the
Second Amendment exists is to prevent
government tyranny
the reason the Second Amendment exists
is to protect your rights the fact that
you own a gun is standing up to the idea
that the government can ever effectuate
that tyranny you know how strongly I
believe in individual liberty and
personal responsibility and our founding
fathers knew that these were the
cornerstones of a great civilization
which is why they created that Second
Amendment to prevent people from
violating the Second Amendment loaning
the rifle is an awesome responsibility
building rifles is no different which is
why I am impressed really impressed with
the folks over at Bravo company
manufacturing BCM Bravo Company started
in the garage a veteran of the US Marine
Corps in Heartland Wisconsin the people
at Bravo Company MFG support the right
of responsible private individuals have
the access and ability to employ the
same tools as civilian law enforcement
as a means of defending ourselves our
loved ones our communities our freedom
should a threatening situation ever
arrive BCM is not a sporting arms
company they design engineer
manufacturer of life-saving equipment
which is the stuff I care about because
I am NOT a hunter I'm not a somebody who
goes to the practice range for fun I'm
somebody who owns a gun because I want
to defend myself and I want to defend my
family and I want a weapon that works
and that's why I trust BCM to learn more
about Bravo company manufacturing head
on over to Bravo Company MFG comm where
you can discover more about their
products special offers upcoming news as
Bravo Company MFG comm Bravo Company MFG
comm okay so the Trump team responds in
this impeachment opening Pat's abalone
says listen they tried to steal the 2016
election by claiming that this was
Russian interference now they're trying
to claim that 2020 is going to be
corrupt unless Trump is a Alstead all of
this is nonsense it's outrageous and the
American people won't stand for it I'll
tell you that right now they're not here
to steal one election they're here to
steal two elections it's buried in the
small print of their ridiculous articles
of impeachment they want to remove the
President Trump from the ballot they
will tell you that they don't have the
guts to say it directly but that's
exactly what they're here to do
okay simple Oni moves along these lines
for most of the most of the day
yesterday so the Democrats are saying
it's completely unfair
these impeachment proceedings are unfair
they're unfair so basically have now the
mirror of what happened in the house in
the House Republicans were saying guys
why don't you wait for the evidence like
why don't you wait for the evidence and
why don't you actually allow us to rebut
that evidence why are you rushing this
thing forward these procedures are
unfair and then we get to the Senate and
Democrats are like why are you rushing
things forward why can't we wait for the
evidence what because the and I'll tell
you why the Republicans are right and
Democrats are wrong has the thing
started in the house the house is where
most of the investigation is supposed to
take place and as simple Oney points out
Democrats spent nearly the entire day
yesterday admitting they don't have the
evidence for the impeachment and then
wining the Republicans won't do their
homework for them for those of you
keeping score at home they haven't even
started yet we're here today we came
hoping to have a trial they spent the
entire day telling you and the American
people that they can't prove their case
I could have told you that in five
minutes and saved us all a lot of time
well that would be nice but nobody's
time was saved instead we just did this
for like the entire day and will
continue to do this for weeks on end
it's just gonna be wonderful
meanwhile then in Patrick Philbin who is
a lawyer for President Trump he's deputy
White House Counsel
he says he says listen they keep asking
for more evidence and they've not
compiled any evidence as of yet so the
Republican argument is basically you
keep whining about the procedures you
didn't do your homework the first thing
that the house managers have done upon
arriving finally in this chamber after
waiting for 33 days is to say well
actually we need more evidence we're not
ready to present our case we need to
have subpoenas and we need to do more
discovery because we don't have the
evidence we need to support our case
this is stunning it's a stunning
admission of the inadequate and broken
process that the House Democrats ran in
this impeachment inquiry that failed to
compile a record to support their
charges it's stunning that they don't
have the evidence they need to present
their case
and that they don't really have a case
this of course is correct Jay Sekulow is
one of the president's lawyers as well
he says listen this is just a partisan
agenda and this whole thing is such
Kabuki theater it is such a waste of
time and the media are the only people
who are truly interested in it if you
ask the average American whether they
are deeply ensconced in this trial the
answer is no they didn't care
four months ago they don't care now
that's not to say they don't have
opinions on it they do but Americans
have opinions on everything I mean you
can pull them on whether they think
Elvis is alive
you can pull people on anything the
country is deeply divided half the
people like Trump half the people hate
Trump and that is reflected in the
polling with regard to impeachment but
if you ask Americans how many of them
are closely following the impeachment
the answer is basically the staff at CNN
and MSNBC and everybody else is like
well got better things to do ma'am
gotta go get my gotta go get my toe
nails filed here's Jay Sekulow
explaining that this is indeed a
Democrat partisan hit why are we here
are we here because of a phone call or
are we here before this great body
because since the president was sworn
into office there was a desire to see
him removed I remember in the Mullah
report there were discussions about
remember insurance policies so my
favorite part of that is when Jay
Sekulow says why are we here and I think
to myself I don't know to fulfill God's
purpose for the long points there it
leads everyone to an existential crisis
as we just sit there not understanding
what in the hell is is going on like
what is this all about so all of this
ends would be dumbest in theatrical
expositions that this was really amazing
so this is late last night Jerry Nadler
partisan hack and Pat's a baloney lawyer
for president Trump also a partisan they
go at each other and it's just it's so
silly and it's so ridiculous it truly is
and then Chief Justice Roberts signs in
he jumps into the fray and he says no
we've got to respect the Senate guys
this is the war room you can't fight in
the war room here's Jerry Nadler idiot
and Pat's
Palani partisan for the president going
at each other while the rest of the
world sleeps and Chief Justice Roberts
saying you can't you're no no the
dignity the dignity of the Institute if
you're worried about the dignity of the
institution's maybe you should have
worried about that when Jerry Nadler got
elected to Congress I am struck by what
we have heard from the President's
Council so far tonight they complain
about process but they do not seriously
contest any of the allegations against
the president the only one who should be
embarrassed mr. Nadler is you for the
way you've addressed this body mr.
Nadler you owe an apology to the
President of the United States and his
family okay and then Chief Justice
Roberts jumped in and went at both of
them and he any suggested that they have
to have respect for this august body and
then he mentions the back in 1905
somebody used the word pettifogging and
then was chided in an impeachment trial
for a non president is this Chief
Justice Roberts says so here's Chief
Justice Roberts signing in and and
commenting on Nadler versus Cipollone II
the showdown I think it is appropriate
at this point for me to admonish both
the house managers and the president's
counsel in equal terms to remember that
they are addressing the world's greatest
deliberative body one reason it has
earned that title is because its members
avoid speaking in a manner and using
language that is not conducive to civil
discourse in the 1905 Swain trial a
senator objected when one of the
managers used the word pettifogging and
the presiding officer said the word
ought not to have been used I don't
think we need to aspire to that highest
standard but I do think those dressing
the Senate should remember where they
are okay so now I'm actually even more
pissed to Chief Justice Roberts than I
am this is so stupid
I'm sorry like we're gonna pretend that
our nation's political bodies they're so
August ok people that was almost beat to
death in the 1850s on the floor of the
Senate so I think we can dispense with
the oh my god
in 1905 we wouldn't even use the word
pettifogging and here we're being mean
to each other on the Senate gentleman
you can't fight in here this is the war
room it's all tiresome it's all stupid
it's all a waste of time
fast forward two weeks it's over we all
know where this is going barring some
unprecedented bombshell which is not
going to drop and a second will gets you
president Trump responding to all of
this in Davos and being very Trumpy
in his response plus you'll get to the
2020 race where tulsi gabbard is now
throwing bombs at Hillary Clinton so
things are getting fun on that side but
first let us talk about how difficult it
is to find the correct part for your car
so if you ever had a situation I have
where your car breaks down and then you
are just looking for a replacement part
something as simple as a battery
sometimes you go to the store and they
are out of the battery you have to go to
a second store and they're out of the
battery and then finally you bring the
battery back home and it's dead well
maybe you should just be using something
called the interwebs because the
interwebs will ensure that you get what
you are seeking how well you check out
Rock Auto calm it's a family business
serving Auto Parts customers online for
20 years go to Rock Auto comm to shop
for auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers they have everything from
engine control modules and brake parts
to tail lamps motor oil even new carpet
whether it's for a classic or daily
driver get everything you need in a few
easy clicks delivered directly to your
door it's great for car enthusiasts I am
NOT a car enthusiast I don't know much
about my car but if you really know your
car and you know all the parts that you
need for your car you can find these
specialized parts over at Rock Auto calm
best of all prices at rockauto.com are
always reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers you
don't get that markup amazing selection
reliably low prices all the parts your
car will ever need over at Rock Auto
calm go to rockauto.com right now see
all the parts available for your car or
truck right shapiro in there how did you
hear about us box so they know that we
sent you again that's Rock auto comm and
right Shapiro's in that how did you hear
about us boxes good for them and it's
good for us as well well the Democrats
basically admitted their agenda today
there's a Democrat in Val Demmings it
was one of the House impeachment
managers and she got up on the floor of
the Senate and she basically just
spilled the beans she says we need to
get this done right now or Trump's gonna
win in 2020 as we all know litigation
would take an extremely long time likely
years not weeks or months this body
cannot permit him to hide all the
evidence while disingenuously
insisting on lawsuits that he doesn't
actually think we can file ones that he
knows won't be resolved until after the
election he is trying to cheat to win so
listen to that if Trump files a lawsuit
because he's asserting executive
privilege and it's gonna take us past
the 20/20 election then he is trying to
cheat however if we just decide to go
forward without the evidence that we
need and try to impeach him that is not
Democrats trying to cheat I mean that is
the Democrats full-scale acknowledging
that this whole thing is about trying to
get it done before the 2020 election
because they're afraid Trump's gonna win
that's all this is that's all this is it
truly amazing admission there from valid
timings okay so President Trump in Davos
being President Trump he has asked about
this whole thing and Trump says I'd love
to show up at my own impeachment trial
I'd love to be there because I want to
stare these bem scary bums right in the
face and believe about go any day and
stare their corrupt faces I'd love to do
it
I don't know don't keep talking because
I'm a he's right that his lawyers might
not brown with him showing up because
Trump you may have noticed has a
tendency toward embellishment at the
very least right his mouth is rather
large but when he said that I've - up
and let these bastards right in the eye
and then drum goes after Jerry Nadler
and again like this you know one of the
reasons that President Trump is
president is because not just of the the
craziness of our politics and the media
and the cultural wars one of the reasons
the Trump is president as I've said
before do you think that Trump murdered
politics or do you think that he's just
the coroner who arrived upon a dead body
and declared it dead when I look at
Chief Justice Roberts hitting there and
saying this august body must never break
down into partisanship this august body
i mean we used to not say pettifogging
in here and then as he Trump and I got
at Trump seriously because that's what I
think that people actually think at
least
when people say the Trump is on us what
they don't mean is that he is honest
about everything he says they mean that
he is authentic right he is what he is
and he is a better reflection of how
Americans think about politics then
Chief Justice Roberts doing me our
August institutions must never ever be
frayed so when you get Trump and he just
says yeah Jerry now there's an S it's
like okay honestly I'll take that above
Chief Justice Roberts doing me
we all respect we're all collegial no or
not this whole thing is a waste of time
it's a waste of our taxpayer money
frankly I'm pissed I have to cover it
here president Trump going after Jerry
Nadler
Jerrold Nadler I've known him a long
time he's a sleaze bag everybody knows
that Pat Sippel only is a high quality
human being I was very impressed with
patty a great emotion yesterday
Pat's a brilliant guy but I've never
seen that emotion and that's real
emotion that's because he knows this is
a hoax and I was very proud of the job
he did I've known I've known Jerry
Nadler for a long time he's opposed many
of my jobs I got him all built very
successfully built in New York like
that's more authentic American politics
then then the Chief Justice Roberts we
must be dignified throughout this entire
idiotic process Trump also wouldn't left
Parnas I love Parnas is this guy who's
been running around claiming that Trump
was giving him direct orders to go
shadow the the ambassador to the to the
Ukraine and that the emmitt left
harnesses being ordered around by Trump
to go do his dirty work in Ukraine
here's President Trump going after life
harness he's so like a groupie he shows
up the fundraisers okay so I don't know
anything about him
I watched Rudy Rudy is a terrific person
great crime fighter the best mayor in
the history of New York City by far
solve the crime problem in New York and
I think it's very unfair the way the
media's treated Rudy Giuliani I will say
this Parnas I don't know other than he
probably contributed the campaign along
with tens of thousands of other people
so where is this going next in just a
second we'll talk about what Democrats
are going to try to do in the last ditch
gamble in order to try and shore up a
case that is
falling apart first if you know anything
about me you've most likely heard me
talk about my art and support for the
pro-life cause you may also remember the
last year i streamed my podcast live
from the March for Life in Washington DC
I give a speech to tens of thousands of
people marching for the cause well you
may not be aware of is how much grief
this caused us from our political
adversaries our advertisers were
actually targeted by left-wing media
watchdogs many of them stood up to those
watchdogs a few of them actually dropped
out that was not the first time nor will
it likely be the last time that we are
attacked in an attempt to shut down
pro-life of voices through astroturf to
boycott attempts against our advertisers
we're not the only targets live action
is one of the biggest voices in the
pro-life movement run by Lila Rose they
continue to do some of the great work in
the space they raise awareness and
education on the abortion issue they do
undercover videos that have exposed
Planned Parenthood and other abortion
clinics for horrific human rights abuses
they've been banned from advertising on
Twitter because they say that we should
defund Planned Parenthood they've been
banned from Pinterest and other social
media platforms I personally support
live action I've given money to live
action right now our daily wire.com
members can to our daily where members
are really important your membership
helps keep the cameras on our
microphones turned up even when the left
is pressuring our sponsors which is why
from now until January 31st a portion of
any daily wire.com membership will be
donated to live action with promo code
live action to support awareness and
education around the world on protecting
the lives of the unborn so again check
us out at daily wire.com when you
subscribe right now and type in live
action a portion of your subscription
will go to a pro-life cause which is
fantastic so joins a Lee Weyer com make
your pro-life voice heard we are the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
so the Democrats seeking desperately for
some way out of this this ditch that
they have dug for themselves are now
contemplating the possibility of trading
witnesses so according to the Washington
Post Rachael bade Robert Costa and
seaman Kim reporting Senate Democrats
are privately mulling a witness trade in
the impeachment trial they are thinking
about allowing hunter Biden to testify
and going along with the testimony of
hundred Biden so long as they get john
bolton to testify publicly most
Democrats have scoffs as the Washington
Post at the growing GOP clamor to hear
former Vice President Joe Biden's son
testify dismissing him as irrelevant to
the charges against Trump accusing
Republicans of trying to distract from
the allegations against the president
behind closed doors a small group of
Democratic senators and aids has begun
to question the lot that logic sounding
out colleagues on whether to back a
witness steal that could lead to
testimony from former national security
adviser John Bolton or other
administration officials with possible
first-hand knowledge of the Ukraine
controversy according to multiple
Democratic officials so now they are
throwing a Hail Mary pass they're gonna
go to Republicans maybe and say listen
well we'll go along with you 100 Biden
thing if you let john bolton testify
first of all that's actually a pretty
good trade for republicans the reason
it's a pretty good trade for republicans
is because john bolton will be heavily
covered he'll say exactly the same thing
fiona hill said it is extraordinarily
unlikely that he says anything like and
that's when his mustaches move and he
says that's when the president told me
that he only wants it joe biden down
before 2020 right which would be the
impeachable offense that is really
really unlikely what is much more likely
that bolton says exactly what his aides
have already said and mirrors what they
said he thought this is a bad idea
he thought that trump was being led
astray by rudy giuliani and all of the
rest and then hunter biden gets up and
guess what the headlines are there
hunter biden a drug-addled loser for
nearly his entire adult life was picking
up a $50,000 a month check because his
last name is biden well his father was
overseeing relations with Ukraine hey
that is not gonna look good for Joe
Biden it ain't gonna look good for
hunter Biden and it's gonna look fairly
good for President Trump who's gonna say
yeah of course I was asking legit
questions about that everyone was asking
legit questions about that they're
members of the Obama administration who
worked for Biden who said that they were
told not to bring up the hunter Biden
situation because Joe Biden just didn't
have the bandwidth but everybody
acknowledged that there was a conflict
of interest everybody so if this is the
way the Democrats want to go good luck
with this Joe Biden
for his part is trying to fight back on
all this blasting Trump's bleep horse
bleep claims he released a new video on
what really happened in Ukraine and this
is his campaign video on hunter Biden
here's what it sounded like the weirdest
Donald Trump fit into all this
he claims that because the vice
president's son Hunter was on the board
of the Ukrainian natural gas company
here is mo the Biden's somehow acted
inappropriately when he advocated for
Viktor shokhin to lose his job the
clinical term for that is force for one
thing Biden was following official
United States government policy which
was in agreement with the EU and other
international partners
number two Shogun's investigation of
your yzma had fallen dormant over a year
before the Vice President did anything
to try and get him out of office okay
that second one is actually under
controversy it's not necessarily
confirmed that the Shokan investigation
was completely normal that Ukraine had
basically left bereavement alone by the
time that Biden wanted to oust that
official as far as Biden following
official US policy well what if he
wanted that policy to be true right what
if he wanted that policy to be correct
because he wanted chokan we don't know
okay
at the very least Biden should not have
been charged of this policy when his son
was picking up bags of cash for being
his son I mean that is literally the
only reason that hunter Biden has any
money to his name is because his last
name is Biden it turns out that half of
Biden's family does this it turns out
that that he's got two brothers who do
this it turns out that his son does it
there are people who probably aren't
even related to Joe Biden who are just
wandering around they have the last name
Biden
it's like Bob Biden just wandering
around somewhere in Kentucky going you
know my last name is you know my last
name is their bag men now working in
Saskatchewan or who are trying to pick
up bags of cash because their last name
is Biden it's pretty amazing so if this
thing goes the way the Democrats are
suggesting if they actually get hunter
Biden up to testify it is not going to
be Joe Biden called to testify in a
truth to power moment it's gonna be
hunter Biden testifying and then if they
do call Joe Biden do you think that Joe
Biden is quick on his feet now media
will cover him as a hero the media will
suggest that he has put upon the media
will suggest that all of this is
nonsense
but here's the reality it's gonna look
good for Joe Biden that he has to
testify about why his son was picking up
bags
cash and he was looking the other way
why he was flying his son to China said
his son could do deals in China using
the vice presidential jet I mean all of
that is going to come up and that ain't
gonna be great for the Democrats which
brings us to the Democratic side of the
2020 race so Hillary Clinton started to
walk back yesterday her comments in The
Hollywood Reporter that she might not
support Bernie Sanders were he the
nominee you'll recall that she did an
interview with The Hollywood Reporter in
which she blasted Bernie Sanders she
said that nobody liked him I'm voting on
the culture around him quote his on line
Bernie bros and their relentless attacks
on lots of his competitors particularly
the women accusing him of permitting
this anti woman culture and then I like
Bernie trended on Twitter for much of
the day some of the other Democratic
candidates 20/20 weighed in both tulsi
gabbard and Tom Steyer tweeted out that
they like Bernie at least when it comes
to Tom Styer the feeling is not mutual
there are 1000 tapes of Tom Styer trying
to be best friends with Bernie and
Bernie brushing him off like Michael
Scott to Toby in the office Sanders said
on a good day my wife likes me here was
Bernie's response to Hillary Clinton's
comments yesterday
Terry Clinton as you know said that as a
senator you got nothing done and that no
one likes you what's your response to
that on a good day my wife likes me so
let's clear the other felon and then
Hillary Clinton came back and she
basically said I don't know what you're
all bitching about she said them really
this is what she actually tweeted I
thought everyone wanted my authentic
unvarnished views fair points to Hillary
but to be serious the number one
priority for our country and world is
retiring Trump and as I always have I
will do whatever I can to support our
nominee so she walks that one back she
walks that one back meanwhile the rest
of the Democratic field continues to be
just a mess Tulsi Gabbard has now hit
Hillary Clinton with a 50 million dollar
defamation lawsuit which is pretty
wonderful she's accusing former
Secretary of State Clinton of
deliberately spreading false accusations
the gabbert is a Russian asset in a
lawsuit seeking upwards of 50 million
dollars in damages according to Fox
news.com and turn an October 20 19
interview with the podcast campaign
headquarters with David Plouffe Clinton
suggested the 2020 presidential
candidate was the favorite of the
Russians and a Russian asset Gabbard
says these statements are not true
Clinton had Clinton should have known
that at the time her brief says rather
than facts or reliable evidence Clint
spaces for the Deaf amatory statements
was one or both of her own imagination
or be extremely dubious conspiracy
theories that any reasonable person and
especially Clinton a former US senator
and Secretary of State would know to be
fanciful wholly unverified and
inherently and objectively unreliable
gabbard's complaint states in no
uncertain terms Tulsi is not a Russian
asset and that neither Russia nor anyone
else controls her or her presidential
campaign as for why Clinton would make
such statements Gabbard claims Clinton
has caught a unique personal connection
to Tulsi that animates her hostility
toward Tulsi and her presidential
campaign so we fun to watch that one
play out in court meanwhile the
Democrats continue to make bizarre cases
for why they ought to be the leaders of
the free world Joe Biden yesterday
suggested that China is not a threat to
the United States and that we should
actually be helping China which is a
weird take when China is attempting to
expand its 5g systems into impoverished
areas of the world simply so that they
can get those nations to be indebted to
them and then they can effectuate their
foreign policy China has been stealing
our intellectual property getting more
aggressive they've been building up
their military resources at an
extraordinary clip according to Joe
Biden though we need to be friends with
them which is because he's been wrong on
everything why wouldn't he be wrong on
this
I mean China is not going to eat our
lunch economically but that's not really
the question the question is whether
they are going to get aggressive in
spheres around the world which they have
and which they did consistently during
the Obama administration meanwhile
Elizabeth Warren desperately trying to
get some attention
so Elizabeth Warren has been dropping in
the polls she's unlikely to win either
Iowa or New Hampshire the current Real
Clear Politics polling average has Joe
Biden up now in Iowa which is horrible
news for the rest of the field if Joe
Biden wins Iowa basically this race is
over the last two polls have Joe Biden
up six on the rest of the field in New
Hampshire Warren is now polling in the
real Club politics poll average fourth
behind Sanders Biden and Budaj
so she is in serious serious trouble
here and so now she's releasing ads
trying to claim that President Trump
fears her the most and thus you should
hand her the nomination even though it
is very obvious and I promise you in the
trump orbit Elizabeth Warren is one of
the ones that they would rather have
they would rather have Warren than have
Biden because Warren has pretty much no
appeal she's off-putting she's a worse
version of Hillary Clinton she lies even
more than Hillary did I mean it's pretty
astonishing the president is concerned
about when against Elizabeth Warren he
fears Elizabeth Warren most the Trump
campaign is internally somewhat
concerned about her they see her as a
threat he's also a little bit nervous
about Warren because she does have an
economic populist appeal that appeals to
some voters that voted for him he's done
everything he can for the wealthy and
well-connected of Elizabeth Warren and I
approved this message
my favorite part of that clip of that
little ad right there is that she
doesn't quote a single person from Team
Trump who says this she just quotes
reporters and commentators had those
aren't all reporters saying the team
Trump is afraid of her and it's like
lawrence O'Donnell from MSNBC who last
talked to someone who voted for Trump
never ever in history yeah good luck to
Elizabeth Warren who is falling apart I
mean it is amazing to watch the collapse
of her campaign it's pretty astonishing
how she the only other person who fell
apart like Elizabeth Warren did in this
race there were a couple others I guess
Kamala Harris didn't bethe erupted but
Warren was widely perceived to be the
pot the probable nominee as late as like
October and now she has completely
fallen out of the conversation which led
to her desperately attempting to smack
Bernie Sanders
meanwhile Peabody jej who was also
considered a possible competitor in the
early States has started to fall apart
because it turns out that when you
expose people who to judge to sunlight
there's not a whole hell of a lot there
yesterday he had his Jeb Bush moment
circle 2016 he actually got up and
begged his audience for applause and it
was supremely awkward by having better
hands guided by better values on those
pulleys and levers of American
government so can I look to you to
spread that sense of hope to those that
you know blood please it's over people
it's over man I'm and when the New York
Times is is patting you on the head and
say be a good little boy and maybe you
can run for a state office yeah you're
you're in a little bit of trouble so
basically this is now boiled down to
Biden versus Bernie in all likelihood
you've got Joe Biden who is not with it
whose son may be called in front of the
senate's testifies to his own corruption
and then you've got Bernie Sanders who
literally said yesterday that he would
tear down and think about tearing down
existing border walls really like it's
not just enough for him to claim that
the border wall is unnecessary Bernie
Sanders now wants to tear down the
existing border walls now here's one
area I've been critical of Tucker
Carlson's takes on Bernie Sanders
because Tucker is what he calls an
economic populist which means that he
believes the government should be deeply
involved in the economy okay but Tucker
is right when he says half of Bernie
Sanders appeal to team Trump is that the
Trump crowd is strong on Boris and
Bernie Sanders used to be strong on
borders right Bernie Sanders used to
believe that if you want a Nordic style
system you actually had to have a Nordic
style immigration policy one of the
dirty little secrets of all of the
democratic socialist countries of
northern Europe is that of the
Scandinavian areas is that they all have
very tough immigration and when they
don't have tough emigration right-wing
parties get elected to reinforce tough
immigration policies Bernie used to be
much tougher on immigration now he has
flipped and he's arguing we should
actually dismantle border walls
intersectionality man it rots your brain
it really does the wall is symbolic and
it represents us too so wouldn't it be
proper to tear that symbol down in order
to achieve that it may be but you know
it's how much those are gonna cost to
tear her down she drew that carrot now I
don't know maybe the answer is yes
that's something that something you're
willing to consider yeah you're willing
existing fencing between us but again a
few cuts are gonna cost me billions of
dollars to tear it down I rather invest
that maybe and their needs for child
care in this country but it's something
you know we can look at we can look at
it maybe it'll be too expensive but on
principle he has no problem with tearing
down border walls
for symbolic reasons when you're out in
the middle of desert we're gonna tear
down the border walls that have stopped
people from crossing that border
illegally in many areas that's Bernie
Sanders that is one of your two leading
candidates with that happening it's no
wonder that there is a new poll showing
that Bloomberg is now rising to fourth
place in a new national poll now you
cannot escape his ads seriously look I
was watching a video on YouTube last
night with my kids about Star Wars and
suddenly there's a Michael Bloomberg ad
on that I was watching a show maybe a
few nights ago on Hulu there's a Michael
Bloomberg ad on that I mean he is
blowing it out when you have too much
money I mean I guess this is what you do
I sound like a Oh see there anyway
according to Politico former New York
Mayor Mike Bloomberg continues to rise
in the Democratic primary field
according to new nationwide polling out
Wednesday as he plows his personal
fortune into widespread advertisements
for his last-minute bid for the White
House the Monmouth University poll found
Bloomberg polling at 9% nationally among
Democratic voters good for a distant
fourth place in a still crowded field
Joe Biden in that poll is still at 30%
Bernie Sanders is at 23% Elizabeth
Warren is all the way down at 14% she's
bad numbers for Elizabeth Warren and
Bloomberg is now rising above southbend
mayor Pete Budaj so Budaj edge is toast
Amy Klobuchar I didn't have any bump in
this poll from that New York Times
endorsement she's now pulling it a
massive 5% Andrew yang just keeps
trucking along the boy Andrew yang he's
still pulling at 3% so Bloomberg's still
has this desperate outside hope that
what happens is that Bernie and Biden
basically split the vote early on and
that Biden is forced to spend a lot of
money that Biden is forced out of the
race and then Bloomberg becomes the sort
of moderate alternative to to Bernie
Sanders the fact is that that is not
going to happen but it is complicating
the race somewhat for the rest of the
field because Bloomberg is buying up all
the ad time and that is driving up rates
fairly dramatically for the rest of the
field meanwhile that rift between the
Sanders crew and the Hillary clue is a
crew they're trying to rectify it right
they're trying to pretend that they are
friends yesterday a few days ago there
is video of Bernie and Elizabeth Warren
arm and arm
smiling again and now you've got Bernie
and and Hillary Clinton who are sort of
trying to kiss and make up although it's
a really really awkward kiss okay well
that's because the Democratic Party is
deeply worried that the divisions in
their own field might sink them ahead of
an election with President Trump who
continues to pull durably in all of the
swing states right now if you had a
ballpark this election
very good shot that Trump loses the
popular vote and wins the electoral
college again very good shot that we
have an exact repeat of 2016 that the
Democrats were most likely to show up
are in all of the blue states where
Alyssa Milano is respected as a
political voice and all of the Democrats
in some of the purple states are less
enthusiastic about some of these
Democratic candidates this is why the
Washington Post is reporting the adviser
that Sanders rifts may help Trump
Democrats fear on Tuesday when Democrats
had hoped to focus American squarely on
president Trump's impeachment trial many
in the party were instead watching an
alarm and dismay was a fresh spat
erupted between Hillary Clinton and the
candidates she defeated in 2016
senator Bernie Sanders everybody is
afraid that the party is falling apart
they should be worried that party is
falling apart because frankly the party
is in some pretty serious trouble they
got a bunch of bad nominees up there
against President Trump who's just Trump
and everybody's baked it into the cake
already already time for a quick thing I
like that a quick thing that I hate so
things that I like today the the Hall of
Fame voting and I'm with Bill James when
it comes to Baseball Hall of Fame voting
is become the Hall of very good that's
how you have Harold Baines in the Hall
of Fame listen I'm a White Sox fan I
like Harold Baines Harold Baines is not
a Hall of Famer but Derek Jeter was
elected to the Baseball Hall of Fame on
Tuesday Jeter was not elected
unanimously he was named on all but one
of the 397 ballots cast by members of
the Baseball Writers Association of
America which is certainly more than
enough to clear the 75% hurdle for
election this was the this was the
second highest voting mark in baseball
history after Mariano Rivera who was
indeed elected unanimously he eclipsed
ken griffey jr. now let's just be frank
about this ken griffey jr. was a way
better player than Derek Jeter Derek
Jeter was a great leader he's a great
face for the New York Yankees he was not
even the best shortstop of his
generation who's maybe the third best
shortstop of his generation
there are many years in which he was
outplayed by but several other
shortstops playing in Major League
Baseball
but it was his consistency he's very
intelligent baseball player
he's very clutch player if you look at
the number of career the career wins for
Derek Jeter it was not it was not
supremely high right his sort of his
sort of advanced statistics he's not an
advanced stat fans are not really fans
of Derek Jeter his career war his career
wins Above Replacement is seventy two
point four that does not tend to rank
extraordinarily high alright Larry
Walker his career war so his career I
let me look it up right now his career
wins Above Replacement Larry Walker who
is right on the borderline he had more
career wins Above Replacement than Derek
Jeter and yet gets fewer votes it just
shows you the glory of playing in New
York but Jeter was a great face for
baseball
I'm glad the Derek Jeter is in the Hall
of Fame now we need to convince the Hall
of Fame voters to stop with this
nonsense where they don't put Kurt
Schilling in the Hall of Fame that is
absolute insanity
hey Kurt Schilling was in fact one of
the great pitchers of his generation the
fact that Curt Schilling is a political
right winger has basically kept Curt
Schilling out of the Hall of Fame for
several years here where he a political
left winger dude would have been he has
he has a higher career war Curt
Schilling does and either Larry Walker
or Derek Jeter his career war is 79.5 he
was if you look at his career strikeouts
two walks ratio it is one of the highest
in baseball history there's no question
that Curt Schilling should be in the
Hall of Fame the fact that is taking him
so long
is simply because baseball writers are
on the left and they don't want to allow
in somebody they disagree with
politically who didn't like Barack Obama
it really is that simple okay time for a
quick thing that I hate and then we'll
get out of here so there was something
that I thought was actually pretty nice
Ayanna Presley who as you know I'm not a
fan right she's the adjunct member of
the squad she's the one everybody
forgets about the Ringo Starr of the
squad but she did something I just
thought doesn't she quite nice she did a
video op-ed in the route in which she
revealed she had alopecia and then she's
now completely bald and she show and she
you know shows that she's bald and
frankly I'm very much in favor of people
showing that medical conditions should
not be stigmatized if you have a medical
condition there are lots of other people
who probably have that same medical
condition and instead of being
embarrassed about a medical condition
talking about it publicly does allow
people to feel comfortable in getting
treatment does
people who feel like they don't have to
hide the medical condition in front of
other people it does make the world
better for people to be clear and and
frankly brave about things like this I
think I didn't see a single person who
objected to this because who the hell
would object to it I mean good for Ayane
presley she's got in a medical condition
there's no reason why she feels that she
should have to wear a wig or something
she concludes the video by revealing her
bald head now there's a piece in The
Washington Post titled black woman's
hair is political and now Ayane
Presley's baldness is - now I understand
the whole argument that for a long time
in the country there were there were
people who discriminated against black
women based on the fact that genetically
speaking black women very often tend to
have curly hair and for some reason
people are against that if you have big
hair they're against that okay that's
very silly discriminating on the basis
of hair is is ridiculous in every
possible way I did but you're looking
for a reason to be pissed off if you are
if you are citing Ayanna Presley's video
about alopecia as some sort of a black
black moment it's just a human bravery
moment I don't know why that's a black
bravery moment this has nothing to do
with race and again there was no
blowback but this piece my person named
Nana F WA Mumford the whole thing is
about how she is she is taking the
fraught black hair conversation into new
territory by focusing on the beauty of
having no hair at all no this had
nothing to do with race she has alopecia
she came out she said she had alopecia
she shows that she's bald good for her
seriously good for her what the hell
does that have to do with race
no we live in a country that thank God
is so racially diverse intolerant that
we now have to make up new excuses to be
mad and frankly the Washington Post can
always find a new excuse to be mad and
to pretend that the legacy of racism
carries on in the non-existent
objections to Jana Presley showing that
she has alopecia and you really have to
stretch to get there alrighty we'll be
back here later today with all your
updates on the impeachment and
everything else you're listening to the
Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling assistant director Pavel
Whitehouse key technical producer Austin
Stephens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam sy events audio
is mixed by Mike foramina hair and
makeup is by Anika Geneva the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 25 yesterday
marked the first full day of president
Trump's impeachment trial the trial
consisted of house impeachment managers
talking and talking and talking and
talking and talking for 13 hours talking
and I was up watching until the very
last minute so you wouldn't have to that
is my service to the American public we
will examine the most important moments
then Hillary throws shade at Bernie
president Trump wrecks the weak elites
at Davos and we announce a fun new
project check it out on a Michael nul
show
[Music]
you